cité phocéenne en quête d'indépendance
du moins d'indépendance sanitaires pour
cela la deuxième adjointe à la mairie
samia ghali après initiative inédite
je pense qu'il est important de créer un
conseil scientifique de la ville de
marseille avec les collectivités la
préfecture li a chu l'ap-hm
l'hôpital privé les marins-pompiers voir
la cci l'éducation nationale tous ces
organismes qui sont au contact de la
situation sanitaire au quotidien il faut
permettre à la mère de marseille d'avoir
des discussions sur le co vide et
d'autres questions et faire en sorte que
des personnalités marseillaise puisse
discuter et faire des propositions
plutôt que de laisser faire l'état la
proposition de l'ancienne sénatrice qui
avaient émergé à la fin du mois d'avril
a été validé par le conseil municipal ce
lundi marseille va se doter de son
propre conseil scientifique et c'est
madame la maire justement michel rubio
la médecin de profession qui devrait le
président et quant au professeur didier
rahout il pourrait lui aussi en être
membres selon samia ghali
ainsi peu de détails sur cette nouvelle
instance ont pour l'instant été dévoilé
le message lui semble clair les élus
marseillais ne souhaite plus dépendre de
certains scientifiques parisien un avis
qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
je rappelle qu'il existe déjà à
l'échelle nationale comme à l'échelle
locale 10 instances compétentes en
matière sanitaire dans cette crise
chacune de ces structures à une
expertise propre et un rôle à jouer
venir y ajouter un machin purement
marseillais ne peut qu'ajouter de la
confusion et de la cacophonie un
désordre déjà inquiétant une annonce qui
intervient au moment où les restaurants
de la métropole
aix marseille peuvent enfin rouvrir
après une semaine de fermeture imposée
par le gouvernement alors que la
capitale placée en zone d' alerte
maximale depuis lundi matin n'a pour le
moment subi aucune fermeture de ses
restaurants